nous avons dévoilé une capsule de
christophe rodde hier le procureur de la
république de bourg en bresse à propos
de cette affaire judiciaire concernant
christian quesada et on a été à la
rencontre des habitants d'autres fils
l'aude le village où habite christian
quesada y ses voisins ont répondu à nos
questions en exclusivité
juste avant l'interview de philippe
petit récap des faits regarde la sphère
christian quesada n'en finit pas
d'alimenter les conversations et de
faire la une des médias et pour cause la
mise en détention provisoire de l'ancien
grand champion du jeu tf1 les 12 coups
de midi pour possession de milliers des
matchs pédophiles et chaque jour
accompagné de nouveaux éléments hier en
exclusivité dans tpm paix le procureur
de la république christophe rodde
s'exprimer sur les détails de
l'arrestation il a notamment donné des
détails très choquant sur le contenu
exact des ordinateurs de christian
quesada il ya des images
clairement ce sont des viols d'enfants
de moins de 10 ans aujourd'hui nous nous
sommes rendus à hauteville longue
village où habite christian quesada pour
aller à la rencontre de ces voisins des
habitants encore sous le choc de la
sphère la réaction en exclusivité des
voisins de christian quesada c'est tout
de suite
ces petites communes de moins de 4000
habitants on est allé à la rencontre de
ces voisins
gilles et benjamin donnerait vous donne
les dernières infos dans un instant ils
ont tous accepté de répondre à nos
questions à condition d'avoir le visage
flouté
car ils ont peur des représailles c'est
la première fois qu'il parle à la
télévision n'a pu rencontrer une de ses
voisines et regardez elle avoue qu'elle
avait déjà eu quelques soupçons sur
christian quesada qui était très discret
dans la résidence regarde bons
sentiments succès j'en parle de lui mon
couteau
voilà donc ça c'était la première action
gilles qu'est ce que c'est alors il
était assez mal intégrés dans le village
il était allé là bas il faut le savoir
parce qu'il voulait absolument quitter
la région parisienne
on a travaillé là-dessus avec benjamin
parce que son passé judiciaire se
déroule surtout en région parisienne
notamment dans le val-de-marne
donc là bas il pensait être tranquille
mais ça s'est pas très bien passé avec
les voisins et lui disait parce qu'il
songeait à déménager je peux vous le
révéler et lui disait qu'il voulait
déménager parce qu'il en avait marre des
sollicitations financières de beaucoup
de gens mais en réalité les gens là-bas
pense que c'est pour une tout autre
raison qu'il songeait quelques semaines
avant son arrestation à partir le
problème quoi bien c'est que il ya un
faisceau de soupçonner beaucoup de gens
enfin pas beaucoup mais quelques
personnes visiblement été au courant du
passé de quesada et il semblerait que
des gens même à l'époque où l'été la
télévision était était au courant leur
pas de tous forcément mais quand on
demande à quelqu'un de faire le ménage
sur ces réseaux sociaux canton ça veut
quand même dire ça prouve que
visiblement il y avait une grosse
présomption il y avait des choses
louches
alors quand elle qu'elle soulevait ou
pas j'en sais rien mais de plus en rien
à son départ tout le monde parle que de
ça en ce moment et qui plante qui est
plein d'excès juste là la vraie question
que tout le monde se pose voilà et qu'on
se pose là dessus ce soir déjà il ya
d'autres qui voulaient réagir là-dessus
oui c'est assez difficile parce que
c'est vrai que l'attitude des voisins
est intéressante
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils avaient autant de
distance avec ses voisins
c'est louche oui mais bon ok on pouvait
dès d'histoire ça il faut qu on peut en
fait être un poil a inscrit alors là ça
va pas envie de faire copain avec tout
le monde et on colle alors qu'il ya une
révélation qui a fait grand bruit depuis
le début du scandale c'est qu'il ya le
fait que la production des douze coups
avait demandé à l'accusation qui est
servie à table mais un blog 1 de la
production qui est bizarre c'est ça
c'est ça qui tient ce qui est gênant on
regarde et on vous explique tout ça
alors que christian quesada est toujours
en détention provisoire les langues se
délient et les questions se multiplient
autour de cette affaire car si on sait
maintenant que le casier judiciaire de
l'ancien champion était très chargé on
se demande pourquoi personne n'a détenus
cette information du côté de la
production avant la participation de
christian quesada à l'émission ce qui
laisse penser que la production se
doutait de quelque chose c'est
l'histoire de ce blog étrange que les
équipes du jeu ont demandé à christian
quesada de supprimer précipitamment
avant sa participation aux 12 coups de
midi
un blog sur lequel il postait de
nombreuses images de très jeunes
actrices se bloque déplacés auraient pu
pousser les équipes à faire des
recherches plus approfondies sur la
personnalité de celui qui allait devenir
le grand champion du programme
alors là ils ont mis la production est
au courant moi jouer son interrogation à
ce point il n'était pas au courant mais
ils ont juste demandé voilà et ils ont
eu ce ce blog voilà qui posait problème
mais je pense que quand on passe six
mois à la télévision tous les jours en
plus c'était les records d'audience de
l'ue sur l'époque je pense pas qu'il
savait tout parce que c'est quand même
compliqué maintenant c'est plus facile
mais à l'époque de savoir tout ce qui
avait été fait parce par ses partenaires
mais il semblerait quand même quand on a
quelqu'un de faire le ménage dans les
réseaux sociaux de fermer un blog ça
veut dire qu'on appelle des soupçons et
qu'on pense qu'il ya des choses pas très
nettes donc savoir tout certainement pas
mais d'un faisceau de soupçons
ni le sénat pierre mais si t'as rien à
te reprocher mois tf1 ils viennent me
voir je vais un jeu télé ferme ton blog
georges ferme pas mon blog je vais à une
émission télé froid tu me demandes de
fario blog moi je pensais qu'ils
voudraient bien théâtre ans qui
viendront non mais si moi je pensais que
l'émission avait déjà commencé qu'ils
étaient déjà englué et qui lui ont dit
sans ton blog tu inverse concernant
stéphane y est pour rien c'est plutôt
serait la justice maintenant qu'il doit
faire les choses fausses faut pas trop
telle une ça va on s'en fout de tf1 ce
soir la grande question vous avez posé
qui était au courant et je les assure
pour le moment
pour le moment on sait que la production
et d'autres gens étaient au courant que
christian quesada était secret bizarre
particulier des pneus mais c'est où
cyril ed petit soupçon l'unrwa d'alors
mais sans les blogs moi je vais vous
dire un truc
après voilà je me fais l'avocat du
diable prêts extérieurs c'est très grave
ce qu'on a appris mais mine de rien a
posteriori les mecs disent tout et
n'importe quoi l'âme 100 fois ici tout
le monde disait il est sympathique on
l'adoré la surface et la presse adressé
ce n'est pas facile de dire après oui
bon on avait des ouais bah moi je le
sentais pas ça va je vous le dis ça tu
sais c'est tout le temps pareil j'ai
décidé moi de vous dire ça je vous en
prie mais sauf que il ya une réalité
judiciaire derrière tout ça si des gens
comme patrice laffont si des gens
subodorait quelque chose cyril l'avait
pas jusqu'où ça allait mais c'est bien
mais c'est la grande question que vont
se poser les enquêteurs excusez-moi
pressent pas le cacher c'est parce que
la production savait alors voila moi
j'ai une qui tue et posé une question à
poser aux téléspectateurs parce que on
va vous montrer d'autres extraits parce
qu'en fait 66 minutes sur m6 fait un
sujet dimanche
voilà sur christian quesada ils sont
même allés aussi dans son village tout
ça est ce que vous comprenez nous on en
parle voilà ça fait trois soirs de suite
qu'on en parle est ce que vous comprenez
qu'on en parle autant qu'on fasse un
truc comme ça dans 66 minutes
parce que moi je vous montre un autre
extrait il ya un monsieur voilà qui nous
a voilà un autre voisin qui a été témoin
de l'arrestation de christian quesada
lundi dernier nous explique comment
s'est déroulé son interpellation qui a
duré plusieurs heures
et c'est vrai qu'il y aura un sujet sur
66 minutes sur m6 vous confirmez
isabelle oui tout à fait mais on ne va
pas regarder ou es ce que vous avez
assisté à l'arrestation de ce qu'est ce
à dire
une voiture à la personne de personnes
dont faisait partie saleh faisant partie
des partants qui ne s'appartient pas
rêver alors voilà je vous dis donc il ya
tout les mêmes les autres chaînes sert
pas que tf1 droukel cécilia direct ces 8
france télévisions est ce que vous
comprenez ça parce que j'ai ouï je
discutais tout à l'heure avec des
copains de journaliste en presse écrite
il m'arrivait ça cartonne sa caracole en
tête de tous les clics vous pas vous
imaginer effectivement vous avez une
émission populaire voudrait un mec
boussieux depuis six mois hélas ici il
s'est cassé donc c'est la double vie de
côté un peu vicieux qui intéresse que
même nous voilà pourquoi je dis toujours
tout il ya plein de gens ici qui nous
disent vous avez pas en parler tous les
soirs lors là mais ce soir la fois qu'on
aura des infos non par loi mais c'est
vrai que voilà un moment moi de moi je
veux dire on va arrêter d'en parler
ce qu'on voit là mais ça c'est par des
lourds en appel et acheter les visuels
n'ont pas la télé c'est vrai mais voilà
mais je vous dis il ya une scène où un
truc dimanche il ya nous voilà on en
fait on fait beaucoup il ya plein de
gens qui disent aussi tout le monde va
parler signalés à bordeaux on a on a un
autre extrait par exemple est aussi un
autre voisin qui a accepté de témoigner
devant le domicile de christian kessé
die nous a parlé de sa personnalité
plutôt discrète
comment était-il en tant que voisin
patti tu me fais bien les ordinateurs à
mon avis elle est beaucoup de relations
compagnie retard voilà alors je vous le
dis la production pour nous n'était pas
au courant donc voilà c'est lui on se
pose la question sera d'ailleurs tous
les producteurs qu'ils ont un produit
attention à 12 coups de midi peuvent
venir sur ce plateau s'exprimer avec
grand plaisir et pour moi je pense que
s'il avait tout court et loris
indirectement oui on oublie l'élément le
principal pourquoi on en a tous parlé
c'est pas parce qu'il l'a fait pendant
six mois il ya eu d'autres maîtres de
midi c'est parce que ce mec il avait une
histoire incroyable il est en arrêt ça
il avait la garde de ses filles ça va
laisser la venue des drames familiaux
tous les gens qui ont envie de gagner au
12 m 2 me au maître de midi se sont
incarnés en lui il a il était le mec qui
a c'est cendrillon maison tessier
c'est pour ça que tout le monde sait la
vérité est vraiment il ya ce qu'ils ont
jalousé il a gagné plus de 800000 euros
il y avait des gens qui souhaitaient le
voir perdre donc avait tout un contexte
qui nous a et puis moi les témoins de la
25e heure ça me gave aussi un peu parce
que ce maintenant qu'ils disent
j'avais vu j'avais ces [ __ ] il ya une
révélation incroyable qu'on a pris c'est
que les policiers étaient déjà venus
plusieurs fois oui j'écris ce ton
quesada ça c'est une vraie révélation
regarde c'est arrivé comme une fois
comme un conte pour enfants on sait pas
ce qui s'est passé c'est le passé 7 et
2019 entre le dépôt de la plainte de la
mineure et l'arrestation à moi ça
m'énerve parce que ça vous énerve que
tout à l'automne nous n'avons passé
alors je vous dis est la vérité chose
comment part c'est une bonne chose parce
que voilà il a cassé moi jdit la casse
et moi révèle l'a10 à la rappeler
maintenant là on est sur lui comment il
ya eu autant de failles
il a eu plein d' enquête il a été
condamné c'est à dire y'en a combien qui
sont dans la nature comme ça qu'on
laisse tranquille parce qu'il s'appelle
pas christian quesada moi j'en ai marre
de ces mecs là parce que ces mecs là
alors je parle pas de lui présente son
innocence c'est des [ __ ] ces mecs là
ils doivent être punis comme les mecs
qui tape les bonnes femmes c'est pareil
on en liberté comme ça comment on peut
avoir des failles c'est ça qui m'énerve
tous les jours je découvre des trucs là
un voisin qui me dit quoi ils sont bien
revenus et la politique est ce que
quelqu'un est mondiale voilà maintenant
non faut pas attendre mais bon il a été
freiné pendant deux ans il a été
condamné mais pas de lui je parle pas de
lui je parle en général ne win mya qui
sont dans la laverie et si on dit ah bah
oui on savait cette écriture scénique à
raison certains fait des choses non mais
c'est toute la question de la récidive
est une vraie problématique neymar
devrait signer mais attention l'ennemi
jean récidive il met d'accord mais quand
on est condamné bien entendu raymond il
ya des cas très graves mais quand on est
condamné
quand la paix n'était j'écoutais elles
soient fermés sylvie lemay qui a fait un
truc
voilà des taux de ma vie tous les jours
récidive sur des airs d enfance vie des
images et on lui dit bon c'est bon bah
on attend que tu récidive
moi tu récidivé alors entre saint gobain
on appris à coudre ses voisines
également commerçant de la commune qui
est très remonté contre christian
quesada qui vivait à quelques mètres de
son domicile
il ya des preuves alors ce qu'ils
faisaient
oui gilles ce que je voudrais dire aussi
c'est que christian quesada s'apprêtait
à s'investir dans une association de
soutien scolaire et ça c'est aussi une
des raisons pour peut-être on
l'apprendra ça c'est une pour laquelle
pour laquelle l'enquêté a abouti à ce
moment là on ne pouvait pas ça rejoint
ce que dit raymond là on ne pouvait pas
le laisser monter ses créations de
soutien avec le réseau quand tu as de
l'argent tu peux acheter des gens pour
dire trouve mans à telle personne trouve
moi telle personne
huit cent mille euros ilham la plainte
en 2017 tu la laisses en liberté deux
ans est cuit cent mille euros dans l'est
maintenant c'était le temps de re goûter
ce d'admirer une enquête difficile par
une séance de baisers alizés désarmés
jean michel maire d info tu suis un peu
d'accord écrit c'est bizarre qui sont
venu toquer mise en faillite et paon
rare c'est pas mesrine facile à trouver
cet homme-là il avait des rendez vous
professionnels médiatique un peu parce
qu'elle a été en panne hier c'était dur
il fallait deux ans pour choper les
médias s'acharnent à lsa on a demandé
aux téléspectateurs s'y trouvent
voilà ce dont parle trouve à la condal
crise lahmar accompagnée vous qu'on en
parle métier 50 50
voyez c'est 50-50 dresse assez partagés
comme il faut qu'on en parle
voilà vous pensez qu'il faut absolument
une enquête continue c'est quand on aura
des infos on en parlera